hi schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid bei
ZDF heute live ihr habt es vielleicht
schon mitbekommen heute gab es eine
Razzia gegen die sogenannte letzte
Generation über die haben wir hier ja
schon öfter gesprochen in mehreren
Bundesländern sieht sie auf den Bildern
wurden Wohnungen von Mitgliedern
durchsucht es wurden konnten gesperrt
und es gibt den Verdacht dass zwei der
Beschuldigten Menschen von insgesamt
sieben Mitgliedern eine Ölpipeline
zwischen Triest und Ingolstadt sabotiert
haben sollen und gegen sieben Mitglieder
der sogenannten letzten Generation gibt
es jetzt aktuell folgenden Tatvorwurf
Bildung bzw Unterstützung einer
kriminellen Vereinigung und der
Hintergrund dafür ist ein
Ermittlungsverfahren der bayerischen
Zentralstelle zu Bekämpfung von
Extremismus und Terrorismus bei der
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft München das
Verfahren wurde laut den äh nach
zahlreicher Strafanzeigen aus der
Bevölkerung eingeleitet ja was sagen die
Aktivisten und Aktivisten in der letzten
Generation dazu die verurteilen diese
Aktion Ion das hier hat ihre Sprecherin
im evanbalen heute auf einer
Pressekonferenz der letzten Generation
gesagt
kannst ja Scholz hat unseren Protest als
völlig bekloppt bezeichnet doch das zum
wiederholten Male unsere Wohnung
durchsucht werden das ist völlig
bekloppt
dass Sie unsere Handys abhören und uns
bis zu fünf Jahre einsperren wollen das
ist völlig bekloppt dass unsere
Lebensgrundlagen laufen zerstört werden
das ist völlig bekloppt
kriminell sind nicht wir die die für das
Klima eintreten kriminell ist die
fehlende politische Führung in dieser
Krise
ja und viele fragen sich heute
lässt sich diese Organisation die letzte
Generation über die Deutschland in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten viel
diskutiert hat lässt die sich wirklich
als kriminelle Organisation einschätzen
ist sie wirklich zurecht aktuell so
stark im Visier was würde so ein Urteil
mit ihren Mitgliedern machen und wie
verhältnismäßig ist eigentlich diese
Diskussion die wir da gerade führen und
darüber wollen wir heute diskutieren und
zwar mit dem Rechtswissenschaftler
Thomas Fischer er war Vorsitzender
Richter am zweiten Straße des
Bundesgerichtshofs und mit Professor
Matthias Jahn vom Lehrstuhl für
Strafrecht an der Goethe Universität in
Frankfurt und wie immer wollen wir hier
auch mit euch diskutieren wenn ihr
Fragen an meine Gäste habt oder einfach
mal eure Meinung zum Thema mit uns
teilen wollt dann macht das gerne hier
im youtube-chat oder per E-Mail an die
jetzt eingeblendete Mailadresse jetzt
begrüße ich aber erstmal meine Gäste
herzlich willkommen herr Fischer
herzlich willkommen Herr Jan schön dass
Sie bei uns sind
wie blicken sie denn auf diesen Tag und
auf diese Razzia hat sie das jetzt doch
überrascht
ja das hat mich überrascht und ich
blicke kritisch auf die vollkommene des
heutigen Tages taucht die Frage auf ob
die Aktivitäten der
Strafverfolgungsbehörden tatsächlich
eine kriminelle Vereinigung treffen und
hier gibt es sehr große Zweifel es gibt
Zweifel an der Frage ob die Taten die
durch die Aktivistin Aktivisten begangen
werden so schwer wiegen dass man
tatsächlich von schweren anlasstaten
reden kann die im Rahmen der
Verhältnismäßigkeit zu fordern sind und
der Sachverhalt ist noch nicht
vollständig überschaubar es gibt
Informationen die die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft in München im
Moment verteilt und aus denen man sich
selbst einen Gesamtbild zusammensetzen
muss dass im Moment eher Umriss und
schattenhaft ist und deshalb ist der
heutige Tag erstmal einer bei dem viele
Fragezeichen an die Aktivitäten der
Strafverfolgungsbehörden zu markieren
sind
die Sprecherin Emil von Wahlen hat ja
gerade gesagt in ihren Augen sei nicht
die letzte Generation kriminell sondern
die fehlende politische Führung in der
Klimakrise würden sie damit gehen
ja über den Begriff der bekloppt hat
möchte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt
mich nicht äußern der steht natürlich
zur
Disposition dann kann jeder so
formulieren wie er möchte
der Gesetzgeber hat ja diese diesen
Straftatbestand der kriminellen
Vereinigung zuletzt 2019 sehr eindeutig
geklärt und hat bei dieser Gelegenheit
auch festgelegt
was die Grenze für die
verhältnismäßigkeitsgrenze die im
Grundsatz für den einen für die
Anwendung dieses dieser Vorschrift sein
soll diese Grenze besteht darin dass
Zweck oder Tätigkeit einer solchen
Vereinigung
darauf gerichtet sein müssen oder sollen
oder
für die Verhalten die Voraussetzung ist
dass sie darauf gerichtet sind das
Straftaten begangen werden die eine
durchstraße von mindestens zwei Jahren
das ist bei etwa bei Straftaten der
Nötigung oder das gefährlichen Angriffs
in den Straßenverkehr ohne Zweifel
gegeben und der Gesetzgeber hat damit
die Grenze der Verhältnismäßigkeit
jedenfalls im Grundsatz eindeutig
festgelegt also die frühere
Rechtsprechung unserer Gerichte die
gesagt hat es muss eine müssen
Straftaten von einer gewissen schwere
sein die ist damit eigentlich
beantwortet worden und ich sehe im
Moment keinen Anlass diese vom
Gesetzgeber getroffene Grenze im Zweifel
zu ziehen
natürlich muss man sagen dass der
Tatbestand dieser
Mitgliedschaft und der Gründung und der
Unterstützung einer kriminellen
Vereinigung in Deutschland eine gewisse
eine eine Geschichte hat die immer
darauf abzielt oder unterstellt es
handelt sich um etwas ganz schrecklich
schweres und kaum ist der Tat bestimmt
dieser Tatverdacht geäußert rückt gleich
die GSG9 an und es drohen
Höchststrafen und so weiter das ist
natürlich das ist gar nicht der Fall der
Tatbestand der
kriminellen Vereinigung 129
Strafgesetzbuch setzt einfach nur voraus
es ist eine feste organisatorische
Struktur gibt die von dem von der
Mitgliedschaft einzelner Menschen
unabhängig ist und die eine zentrale
entscheidungsbildung hat wie man sich
vielleicht einen ein Verein vorstellen
kann
so allgemein und dass diese Vereinigung
die entweder den Zweck hat Straftaten zu
begehen oder dass die Tätigkeit dieser
Vereinigung hauptsächlich daran besteht
solche Straftaten zu begehen
und ich meine eigentlich dass jedenfalls
die Teile der
Zusammenschlusses letzte Generation die
im sogenannten Kategorien erfasst werden
nach der nach der Selbstbeschreibung der
Organisation und die einer Kategorie
angehören die sagt wir sind bereit
Straftaten zu begehen und auch bereit
dafür uns bestrafen zu lassen
gegebenenfalls sogar ins Gefängnis zu
gehen ich muss einmal kurz reingehen
weil sind wir schon ganz schön
juristisch geworden und ich würde gerne
einmal alle Zuschauer und Zuschauerinnen
da draußen abholen die sich gerade
fragen Bildung einer kriminellen
Vereinigung was genau muss ich mir
darunter vorstellen lassen uns danach
gerne weiter diskutieren Jonas Cup hat
und mal für uns wie bitte
ich habe gerade versucht diese Frage zu
beantworten wir können sofort weiter
diskutieren wir haben noch mal ein
kleines Stück zusammengebaut was das für
unsere Zuschauer Zuschauer noch mal
zusammenfasst lassen diskutieren
Grundlage für Ermittlungen zur Bildung
oder Unterstützung krimineller
Vereinigung ist § 129 des
Strafgesetzbuchs demnach müssen einer
Vereinigung mehr als zwei Personen
angehören die ein gemeinsames Ziel
verfolgen kriminell wird eine
Vereinigung wenn sie Straftaten begehen
will die mit mindestens zwei Jahren
Höchststrafe bestraft werden können der
Zusammenschluss ist auf Dauer angelegt
und besitzt feste Rollen zu schreiben
die klebeaktion der sogenannten letzten
Generation gelten juristisch als
Nötigung die Höchststrafe liegt bei drei
Jahren ob jemand als Mitglied einer
kriminellenvereinigung verurteilt wird
entscheiden Gerichte so geschehen etwa
bei Mitgliedern des Rockerclubs Bandidos
oder rechten hooligan-gruppen
ja wir haben es gerade gehört
Rockerclubs Bandidos Rechte Hooligans
ich denke auch deswegen ist heute
öffentlich die Verwunderung zum Teil
groß das jetzt eben auch klimaaktivisten
die sich auf die Straße kleben in die
gleiche Kategorie gehören sollen herr
Fischer können Sie denn diesen Zweifel
in der Öffentlichkeit vielleicht auch
von Laien nachvollziehen weil man so
sagt hey die Vergleichsgröße sind jetzt
Rockergruppen und Hooligans nein die
Vergleichsgröße für die Anwendung eine
Straftatbestand sind nicht Rocker und
Hooligans sondern sind die
Tatbestandsmerkmale die im Gesetz stehen
ich habe gerade schon versucht das zu
erläutern und ihre Anspieler hat ja
gerade Bestand zitiert und daraus ergibt
sich dass das natürlich nicht nur für
Rocker Geld und erst recht nicht für
Terroristen und sondern dass das für
jede
Vereinigung mit einer solchen Struktur
grundsätzlich gilt die bereit bleiben
beabsichtigt oder deren Tätigkeit darauf
abzielt Straftaten zu gehen und zwar
bestimmte Art und bestimmter schwerer
die sind hier aber gegeben
Zweifel daran die Voraussetzungen sind
erfüllt jetzt muss man sagen mit
natürlich haben diese Leute
gute Ziele aber wir wissen ja dass zum
Beispiel die guten Fernziele für eine
für eine Nötigung
nicht einfach
so genannt werden können dass man sagt
ich bin für den Frieden oder für die
Rettung der Welt oder für gegen die
gegen den Hunger oder sonst was
sondern dass die Fernziele zunächst mal
unabhängig
keine Rolle spielen wenn jemand sagt ich
bin für die Rettung der deutschen Kultur
darf er trotzdem nicht alle
hochladen zerstören oder fensterschaden
zerstören in denen ausländischen
Literatur verkauft wird und wenn jemand
sagt ich möchte Tempolimit 130 einführen
oder möchte die Bundesregierung dazu
nötigen das einzuführen darf er trotzdem
nicht durch die Straßen ziehen und alle
reichen von Autos zerstören
soweit habe ich da mit dem Tatbestand
ehrlich gesagt keine Probleme und auf
ihre Ausgangsfrage zurückzukommen wenn
ein Anfangsverdacht besteht und ich
glaube dass er besteht in diesem Fall
dann ist ja die Staatsanwaltschaft dazu
verpflichtet ein Ermittlungsverfahren
nicht
gegeben kann man nicht absehen und was
dabei rauskommt ist ja zunächst mal
völlig
Herr Jahn teilen Sie diese Einschätzung
nein ich teile die Einschätzung nicht
und zwar unter drei Aspekten erstens die
Straftaten die begangen werden müssen
müssen eine Gewinde gewisse
mindestschwere haben Herr Fischer hat
natürlich recht im Gesetz steht das muss
mit einem Höchstmaß von mindestens zwei
Jahren Freiheitsstrafe bedroht sein nun
ist es so diese letzte Änderung von der
Fischer gesprochen hat kam durch eine
Änderung europäischen Rechts im
europäischen Recht in dem entsprechenden
rahmenbeschlusszeit zur
Terrorismusbekämpfung und nun Brüssel
ist kein Kind von Traurigkeit wenn es um
Terrorismusbekämpfung geht wir denken an
die geldwesten in Frankreich wir denken
an die Vorgänge in Griechenland war die
Grenze noch bei vier Jahren
Freiheitsstrafe gezogen das heißt
Deutschland hat selbstständig über
obligatorisch diesen Rahmen Beschluss
umgesetzt und ich glaube das sehr gute
Gründe dafür sprechen dass diese
überobligatorische Kriminalisierung
im Rahmen der Auslegung nämlich bei der
Prüfung der Verhältnismäßigkeit der
Maßnahmen eine Rolle spielen muss es
stimmt also nicht dass man einfach nur
sagen kann hier geht es um Straftaten
wie Nötigung oder um Gefährdung des
Straßenverkehrs sondern man muss ganz
genau darauf schauen ob die Straftaten
die dort begangen worden sind auch
tatsächlich die öffentliche Sicherheit
also das recht gut diese
Straftatbestandes gefährdet haben und
das kann man jedenfalls für das was man
gerade im Einspieler sieht für die
klimakleber Aktivisten in ihrer
klassischen Performance nicht sagen
natürlich gibt es jetzt erste Indizien
dahin das beispielsweise öffentliche
Betriebe gestört worden sein könnten die
Ölversorgung davon war ja die Rede in
Bayern und möglicherweise auch anderen
Ort wenn sich diese Hinweise verdichten
sollten dann muss man erneut in einer
Abwägung eintreten aber bisher ist mir
das vom Sachverhalt her noch nicht ganz
klar geworden was die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft in München
hier an Sachverhaltsinformationen hat
muss ja vielleicht auch noch nicht klar
sein in diesem Stadium das Verfahrens
aber die Fragezeichen bleiben zweiter
Punkt das Gesetz dass er Fischer ja zu
Recht aufruft sagt ausdrücklich wenn die
Begehung von Straftaten nur ein Zweck
oder eine Tätigkeit von untergeordneter
Bedeutung ist dann liegt keine
kriminelle Vereinigung vor das heißt das
Leitbild und das ist tatsächlich auch
historisch so ist letztlich eine
kriminelle Struktur wie die Mafia und da
wird man natürlich sagen können und auch
müssen deren Hauptweg ist die Begehung
von Straftaten das ist evident bei den
klimaaktivistin Aktivisten liegt der
Hauptweg das ist ja heute auf der
Pressekonferenz noch mal deutlich
geworden in einem Zweck den auch das
höchste deutsche kriegt das
Bundesverfassungsgericht für besonders
schützenswert hält nämlich Aktivitäten
um unsere natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen
zu bewahren und zwar an der
Klimakatastrophe zu bewahren und deshalb
muss man sehr genau darauf schauen ob
man tatsächlich sagen kann hier geht es
um Straftaten als Selbstzweck ich glaube
auch dass ihr Straftaten begangen worden
sind die sind aber nicht so schwer oder
geht es hier um Straftaten als
symbolische Handlung als eine
Möglichkeit im Öffentlichkeit her zu
stellen und dann muss man im Rahmen der
Verhältnismäßigkeit auch diese Fragen
beantworten und die sind mir bis jetzt
durch die Ermittlungsbehörden noch nicht
hinreichend beantwortet da werden wir
die nächsten Tage noch abzuwarten haben
ob hier noch nachgeliefert wird
ja wir sehen die Meinungen gehen zu
diesem Punkt auf jeden Fall auseinander
ich würde gerne einmal gemeinsam mit
Ihnen auf einen Tweet gucken besser
gesagt auf einen Screenshot der Website
der letzten Generation da haben Besucher
der Website heute morgen diese Zeilen
lesen können da steht die Homepage der
letzten Generation wurde im Auftrag der
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft München
bayerische Zentralstelle zu Bekämpfung
von Extremismus und Terrorismus durch
das Bayerische Landeskriminalamt
beschlagnahmen die letzte Generation
stellt eine kriminelle Vereinigung gemäß
Paragraph 129 im Strafgesetzbuch da und
das Besondere daran ist dass im Laufe
dieses Tages die bayerische Staatsanwalt
oder die die Generation
Staatsanwaltschaft München das
gewissermaßen zurückgezogen hat
mittlerweile liest man dann nur noch es
besteht ein Verdacht auf die Bildung
einer kriminellen Vereinigung und das
ist ja schon etwas was heute viele
kritisiert haben ging das nicht ein
bisschen schnell das heute morgen auf
der Website der letzten Generation schon
diese Zeilen zu lesen waren herr Fischer
ja ich glaube auch dass das zu weit geht
wir sind ja in einem Stadion indem man
Anfangsverdacht besteht und die
Staatsanwaltschaft ist vom Gesetzes
wegen der zu verpflichtet einem
Anfangsverdacht nachzugeben das sagt uns
das sogenannte Legalitätsprinzip und bei
einem Anfangsverdacht der sich
jedenfalls mal mit der mit der formellen
Gesetzeslage in Deutschland in
Übereinstimmung befindet muss die
Staatsanwaltschaft nicht vorab schon
sagen das ist möglicherweise mit EU
Recht
nicht vereinbar ist und wenn es so ist
dann muss natürlich die
Staatsanwaltschaft bei Anleitung eines
Ermittlungsverfahrens darauf hinweisen
und davon ausgehen und ist auch deutlich
machen wenn Sie Interesse Erklärung
verteilt dass es sich nicht um eine
Feststellung feststehende Feststellung
handelt nicht um einen endgültigen
Sachverhalt sondern nur ein Verdacht und
deshalb ist nach meiner Ansicht diese
offenbar
Mitarbeiter der Staatsanwaltschaft oder
der Polizei weiß ich jetzt nicht genau
eingestellt übermerkung die LG sind eine
kriminelle Vereinigung für immer der
Spendenzahl macht sich der Unterstützung
strafbar
schlicht und ergreifend
unzulässig gewesen und deshalb glaube
ich ist es vollkommen zu Recht wieder
aus dem
von der Homepage gestrichen worden und
da steht jetzt halt es gibt ein Verdacht
und daraus kann sich jeder ableiten was
er will auch wie der Verdacht ausgeht
wie die Prüfung ausgeht ist vollkommen
offen das hat ja mehr voll richtig
dargestellt und die bloße die bloß
Eröffnung eines Ermittlungsverfahrens
aufgrund eines Anfangsverdachts reicht
hier wie auch in allen anderen Fällen
des deutschen Strafrechts und
Strafprozess vielleicht
selbstverständlich nicht aus um schon
vorab eine vorurteilung oder eine Schuld
Feststellung zu treffen
jetzt stand ja bei dieser Vorwurf heute
relativ lange im Raum bzw auf dieser
Website da kann man sich ja schon fragen
so ein Vorwurf ist verbunden mit
gewissen Vorurteilen mit einem Ruf der
jetzt erstmal an der letzten Generation
haftet gibt es in so einem Fall
vielleicht sogar Konsequenzen für
Behörden her
also es geht ja im jetzigen Stadium des
Verfahrens vor allen Dingen mal um das
Symbol das hier kommuniziert werden
sollte dass wir übrigens bisher
eigentlich nur aus amerikanischen
Strafverfahren kennen wo das FBI
seitenbeschlagnahmen
illegaler Provenienz und das dann
sozusagen prominent platziert und
anzeigt der eigentliche Punkt ist doch
diese Aktion zeigt worauf die Bejahung
eines Anfangsverdachts des Bestehens
einer kriminellenvereinigung im
kernzielt es geht doch nicht so sehr
darum dass jetzt ernsthaft davon
ausgegangen wird dass Aktivistin
Aktivisten eines Tages vor einer
Staatsschutzkammer oder gar eine
Staatsanwalt eines Oberlandesgericht
stehen und sich dort zu verantworten
haben für diesen wegen dieser kriminelle
Aktivitäten nein es geht um das große
Besteck der Strafprozessordnung es geht
um die maximal
eingriffsinvasiven Maßnahmen die die
Strafprozessordnung ermöglicht also
beispielsweise
Telekommunikationsüberwachung
beispielsweise L Handgriffe
beispielsweise online Durchsuchung oder
eben wie heute
Durchsuchungen in einigen Fällen
natürlich richterlich genehmigt worden
sein müssen und das soll erzeugen dass
finde ich ist die richtige Botschaft die
eine der Damen auf der Pressekonferenz
geäußert hat ein bestimmtes Klima und in
diesem Klima soll
verhindert werden das Aktivistin
Aktivisten sich weiter in der Art
betätigen wie wir das in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten erlebt haben das hat
sicherlich etwas mit Prävention zu tun
das ist aber nicht die Aufgabe des
Strafverfahrens jedenfalls nicht seine
Hauptaufgabe und das hat möglicherweise
auch etwas zu tun mit heraufziehenden
Wahlkämpfen wo man natürlich auch darauf
schielt dass viele Bürgerinnen und
Bürger sich fragen ist der Staat aktiv
genug Macht der genug und ist er dafür
auch tatsächlich dazu tatsächlich in der
Lage
unsere Straßen von diesen
klimaaktivisten Aktivisten die zur
Unzeit sich festkleben freizuhalten da
gibt es offenbar Zweifel und dann ist
natürlich eine solche jetzt im Wortsinne
im Internet sichtbare plakative Aktion
mit der Beschlagnahme von Webseiten und
der Hinterlegung eines Banners wir tun
was ein probates Mittel um in einer Art
von Befreiungsschlag kommunizieren zu
können jetzt haben Aktivitäten der
Strafverfolgungsbehörden eingesetzt die
diesen Umtrieben ein
sozusagen ein Stoppschild
hinstellen und das ist etwas da sagt der
Fischer völlig zu Recht was der
Staatsanwaltschaften die Polizeibehörden
auch nicht ansteht also das
Ermittlungsverfahren das jetzt hier in
Gang kommen mag ist ein staatliches
Ermittlungsverfahren dass sich nicht
dadurch abspielen sollte das ist
sozusagen im Internet weiter
kommuniziert wird um Aktivisten
Aktivisten einzuschüchtern das heißt man
könnte sich jetzt in diesem Kontext
schon fragen ob das nicht gewissermaßen
auch politisch motiviert ist
also darüber will ich mich nicht in
Spekulationen ergehen ich gehe zunächst
mal davon aus dass die Staatsanwältinnen
und Staatsanwälte die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen in Bayern ihre Arbeit tun
Anfangsverdacht prüfen und wenn sie ihn
bejahen dann die wir Fischer zu Recht
sagt dann dem Legalitätsprinzip
notwendige Maßnahmen ergreifen natürlich
kann man nicht die Augen davor
verschließen dass etwa in Berlin die
Frage des Plans oder verneins der
Voraussetzung einer kriminellen
Vereinigung Gegenstand politischer
Erwägung auf Ebene der Justizsenatorin
ist und dass die Fragen in Brandenburg
auch bis hinein in die Ebene der Politik
begleitet worden sind beispielsweise
durch Zustimmung zu den Aktivitäten der
Staatsanwaltschaft in Neuruppin wäre das
verkenntnis naiv natürlich sind das hier
auch politische Themen die verhandelt
werden das muss aber ganz klar
geschieden werden von den Tätigkeiten
der Staatsanwaltschaften bei denen ich
bisher keine Indizien habe dass dort aus
sachbieten möglicherweise auch
politischen oder parteipolitischen
Motiven zu den maximal invasiven Mitteln
der Strafprozessordnung gegriffen worden
ist aber die Gefahr dass dieser Eindruck
entsteht die besteht
herr Fischer teilen Sie diese Meinung
naja die hier Betroffenen Aktivisten
also die Mitglieder dieser
Zusammenschlusses letzte Generation
begründen ihre Tätigkeiten ja durchaus
und rundum politisch also ist natürlich
die Reaktion des Staates darauf in einer
gewissen Weise immer irgendwie politisch
motiviert was Sie mit Ihrer Frage was in
der Frage sozusagen mitschwemmt ist ja
bisschen sachwidrig politische
instrumentalisiert und dazu muss man
sagen
ist ja doch eigentlich erstaunlich dass
immer das dass diese Frage
gleichzeitig mit dem Hinweis darauf
gestellt wird dass diese Aktivisten
diese Täter hier um das mal sozusagen
jetzt sehr verdienstvolle politische
Ziele verfolgen
man hat bisher noch nicht darüber
diskutiert ob das möglicherweise eine
versuchte Nötigung von Verfassungsorgan
ist sondern interessanter
Straftatbestand der noch nicht
in diesem Zusammenhang die Aktivisten
sagen wir werden unbeteiligte Menschen
so lange nötigen und zwar Menschen die
sich den nicht entziehen können und die
dem auch gar nichts entgegensetzen
können ich kann so elektrisch und so
sparsam und so wenig Farbe ich will ich
falle diesen Aktivisten trotzdem zum
opfern muss stundenlang mit
Zahnschmerzen in den Stau stehen oder
schwere wirtschaftliche Folgen haben
weil ich wichtige Termine verpasse und
die sagen das ist jetzt auch mal egal
wir möchten das Olaf Scholz und die
Regierung ein Tempolimit einführt oder
ein Bürgerrat oder was auch immer für
sinnvolle oder weniger sinnvolle
Maßnahmen da gefordert haben das sind ja
politische Gründe und man sagt ja die
wollen ja nur das Beste dann kann man ja
nicht gleichzeitig sagen es ist falsch
dieses beste sozusagen in den in den
gesamt Rahmen des Strafgesetzbuches und
der
vom strafgesetzbuch
verantwortungsgrundgesetzes
vorgegebenen Rahmen zu stellen man kann
fast jedes
kann fast jede Tat die man sich
vorstellen kann zum Beispiel auch viele
Daten von rechtsgerichteten
Gruppierungen
wenn man die nur lang genug abstrahiert
kann man daraus durchaus
anerkennenswerte Ziele irgendwie
formulieren es geht um Deutschland es
geht um Sicherheit es geht um Freiheit
es geht um eine deutsche Sprache oder
was auch immer ja und das kann man wenn
man das nur genügend wenn man das nur
genügend abstrahiert kann man sagen ja
dann muss das halt auch möglich sein und
dann darf sich der Staat ja nicht
einmischen das glaube ich ist nicht
richtig denn eine eine mit Gewalt und
das ist ja in der Rechtsprechung
eigentlich entschieden mit Gewalt
durchgeführte Nötigung völlig
unbeteiligten Menschen allein zu dem
Zweck
diese Menschen als Mittel zu
instrumentalisieren um Aufsehen zu
erregen und um in diesem Fall
ausdrücklich sogar die Bundesregierung
zu irgendwelchen Maßnahmen zu nötigen
ist rechtswidrig und das muss man ja
nicht weiter relativieren natürlich ist
der Zweck Klimaschutz an guter Zweck
da gibt es keinen Zweifel daran aber
wenn man solche Straftaten zu begehen
und wenn man eine Organisation gründet
die in ihrer Struktur mit
Hilfsorganisation mit Unterstützung
mit psychologischen
Eingreiftruppen mit anwaltsgruppen und
so weiter mit mit einer zentralisierten
Entscheidung darüber wo welche Aktionen
stattfinden und wenn man dabei nicht nur
in Kauf nimmt sondern gezielt darauf ab
sondern darauf abzielt
10.000 möglichst viele Menschen
möglichst lange zu bloß en Instrumenten
und lösen Objekten der eigenen
Demonstration zu machen dann ist es eine
Straftat die die Voraussetzung nicht nur
den Nötigung der Welt sondern die wenn
sie so organisiert durchgeführt wird
auch die Voraussetzung einer
kriminellenvereinigung erfüllt
jedenfalls in dem Rahmen in dem das vom
Gesetz
vorgesehen ist
ja apropos Bundesregierung lassen wir
uns mal auf die Reaktion der
Innenministerin Nancy Feser blicken
die heutigen Maßnahmen zeigen dass der
Rechtsstaat sich nicht auf der Nase
herumtanzen lässt Polizei in Justiz
neben Straftaten nicht hin sondern
handeln was so wie es ihre Pflicht ist
die rote Linie im Rechtsstaat ist aus
meiner Sicht ganz klar das habe ich ja
schon mehrfach gesagt legitimer Protest
endet immer dort wo Straftaten begangen
werden und andere in ihren Rechten
verletzt werden
Herr Jan wie bewerten sie denn den
Umgang der Politik bisher mit der
letzten Generation es gibt ja jetzt auch
einige Stimmen die sagen man treibt
eigentlich diese Gruppe gerade mit
diesen Maßnahmen eher noch in die
Radikalisierung und die Politik müsste
offen auf sie zugehen
also es werden Märtyrer gemacht das
glaube ich kann man nicht erkennen und
natürlich kann man auch nicht erkennen
das hat der Fischer finde ich auch
deutlich werden lassen das ist die
Aktivistin Aktivisten natürlich auch
darauf auslegen und darauf Aussehen den
Rechtsstaat bis auf das Äußerste zu
reizen um dann möglicherweise als
Märtyrer dazu stehen aber das was Frau
Feser eben gesagt hat vermischt die
Ebenen und auch wie sich Herr Fischer
geäußert hat geraten mir zwei Ebenen zu
sehr durcheinander das ist einmal die
Ebene der straftatbegehung ich glaube
dass vieles dafür spricht dass die
meisten begehungsweisen etwa vom
festkleben auf Straßen oder wie wir das
eben noch mal im Einspieler gesehen
haben
vom beschmutzen von Kunstwerken oder von
öffentlichen Gegenständen wie dem
Grundgesetz Denkmal am Berliner
Reichstag das ist hier im Straftaten
handelt und das ist dabei wiederum
Straftaten handeln soll ist glaube ich
sehr gut vertretbar weil es die
Aktivistin Aktivisten genauso wie beim
klassischen zivilen Ungehorsam darauf
anlegen wollen dass eine rote Linie
überschritten wird nämlich die Grenze
zur Strafbarkeit das sichert die
öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit und
gewissermaßen wird damit auch erste
glaubhaft dass es sich um eine so
existenzielle Bedrohung durch die
Klimakrise handelt weil die Aktivistin
Aktivisten sich hier eben auch selbst
existenziell engagieren und sogar das
Risiko eines Strafverfahrens eingehen
das ist die eine Ebene des Protestes das
ist die Ebene von nennen wir es
primärstraftaten aber der Schluss dass
daraus eine kriminelle Vereinigung
entsteht das ist mir zu kurzschlüssig ja
und das wird auch in dem Einspieler mit
dem Statement von Frau Feser etwas
miteinander vermischt weil jetzt hier
das symbolhafte überhand also dieses wir
tun etwas gegen diese Empörung natürlich
ist es einfacher die Geldquellen
abzuschneiden die Kommunikation zu
erschweren die Aktivisten vom Internet
zu trennen als im
einzelfallstrafverfolgung zu betreiben
und für das zweite für die kriminelle
Vereinigung bin ich nach wie vor nicht
davon überzeugt dass die Straftaten um
die es geht eine schwere erreichen eine
wenn man so eine Gravität erreichen dass
die öffentliche Sicherheit durch diese
Vereinigung in mitleidenschaftgerät ich
kann nicht erkennen wie ein klimakleber
wenn er wie Herr Fischer das
nachvollziehbar dargelegt hat dazu führt
dass jemand zwei Stunden lang später
nach Hause kommt die öffentliche
Sicherheit in einem starken Sinne
verstanden beeinträchtigt sondern das
ist eine Unbequemlichkeit das ist im
Einzelfall empörend
viele von uns ich eingeschlossen haben
auch unter diesen Aktivitäten schon
gelitten aber dass ich mich in meinem
Sicherheitsgefühl beeinträchtigt fühle
das ist glaube ich noch mal ein weiterer
Schritt den ich im Moment noch nicht zu
gehen bereit bin wenn sich Hinweise
verdichten wie gesagt das das Anlagen
etwa die der so wie Ölpipelines die der
öffentlichen Versorgungssicherheit
dienen tatsächlich konkret gefährdet
worden sind dann muss man den
Sachverhalt noch mal neu bewerten aber
das ist derzeit allenfalls in Umrissen
erkennbar
da frage ich doch direkt mal Herrn
Fischer fühlen sie sich denn aktuell in
ihrem Sicherheit in ihrer in ihrer
Sicherheit in Deutschland beeinträchtigt
durch die letzte Generation
die Voraussetzungen des Tatbestands ja
Mitgliedschaften einer
kriminellenvereinigung ist nicht dass
sich der Einzelne Fischer in seiner
Sicherheit bedroht fühlt das ist immer
der das gesetzgeberische Motiv da muss
man schon unterscheiden meine ich und
natürlich kann man sich in seiner
Sicherheit bedroht fühlen wenn man
Opfer einer solchen Straftat werden wenn
vorne Menschen stehen die mit Gewalt
also zum Beispiel Bäume fällen oder
Container über die Straße sperren legen
damit wirklich 10.000 von Menschen
möglichst lange da stehen und sich nicht
auf fortbewegen können ist es halt eine
Straftat und ob man die Straftat jetzt
für schwer genug hält oder nicht das ist
eine Frage die der zunächst mal der
Gesetzgeber zu entscheiden hat ich meine
der Gesetzgeber hat es entschieden ein
paar davon 129 Absatz 1 Strafgesetzbuch
und immer fort immer wieder neu diese
moralische
Aspekt einzubringen das ist doch nette
Menschen sind und sehr viel gute Ziele
verfolgen das ist ja alles vollkommen
richtig verfolge auch ich habe ja nichts
gegen das Ziel das Klima zu retten oder
die Bundesregierung zu dazu zu bringen
ein Tempolimit einzuführen oder
ähnliches ich meine nur dass ich das
Menschen zum Beispiel zurecht bestraft
werden wenn Sie zu diesem Zweck
alle Autoreifen zerstechen von auch von
geparkten Autos oder oder sonst
irgendwelche Straftaten begehen die ja
die sich niemand gefallen lassen muss
und und niemand muss sich doch mit
Gewalt daran hindern lassen und nötigen
lassen sich zum
sich frei zu bewegen solange das
zulässig ist und
die die bloße Berufung auf einen auf
einen moralisch hochstehendes Fernziel
ist ja
die auch
weder gesetzlich vorgesehen noch ist sie
irgendwie plausibel weil diese die ist
ja vollkommen beliebig man kann es ist
wenn man sagt ich bin für den Frieden
und für und für das Leben der Menschen
oder für die ich bin für das menschliche
Leben darf man trotzdem nicht alle
Abtreibungsärzte oder oder
Abtreibungskliniken
blockieren und alle Frauen die diese
Gynäkologen aufsuchen mit Gewalt dazu
nötigen da wieder nach Hause zu gehen
man darf es nicht es ist eine Nötigung
und wenn man dann sagen ich bin aber ein
Freund des Lebens
ändert das nicht daran und so kann man
sich viele Beispiele ausdenken ein
bisschen so richtig rechtsradikalen und
die wirken
Straftaten bei denen niemand das ein
Zweifel hat das diese strafbar wäre und
wenn man die Leute fragt dann oder
irgendwie reichsbürgerschaft hat wird
man von denen auch irgendwelche Ziele
genannt bekommen die sich moralisch
hochstehen kann
der Grundsatz ist dass Moral und
Strafrecht zwar zusammenhängen aber
nicht identisch sind und die bloße
Berufung auf ein moralisch hochstehendes
Ziel kann nicht dazu führen dass man für
sich selbst und seine Gesinnungsgenossen
in Anführungszeichen Ausnahmen von
gesetzlichen Regeln
postuliert an die sie alle anderen
halten müssen wenn hier wenn
irgendjemand diese
die
Mitglieder dieser Organisation einsperrt
oder nötigt oder entführt oder sonst
irgendwas und sagt so das tun wir jetzt
für die Sicherheit Deutschlands denn wir
werden die sicher die ersten die sagen
die Sicherheit Deutschlands reicht aber
nicht aus und nicht der Freiheit zu
haben sondern man musste etwas
nachweisen man muss ich habe dich ja
nicht angegriffen was habe ich denn
getan und so weiter und ich denke dass
wir in einer Gesellschaft leben die auch
darauf angewiesen ist und eine doch
sozusagen
bemerkenswert positive Tradition daran
hat solche allgemeinen Regeln
einzuhalten dahinter steht ja auch immer
die Gefahr das passiert wenn diese wird
diese Organisation Erfolg haben wird die
Bundesregierung sich da nötigen lassen
dazu ein Tempolimit einzuführen oder
ohne sonstige Maßnahmen zu ergreifen die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist außerordentlich
gering was bedeutet das für diese
besehlten jungen Menschen überwiegend
jungen Menschen sie werden enttäuscht
werden und was passiert mit einer
solchen Organisation die sagt es geht um
alles es geht um unser Leben und wird
dafür sind wir bereit alles zu tun und
alles zu riskieren
darf ich eine frage mal einwerfen Punkt
sind zu den jungen Menschen
da kriege ich gerade ganz viele Fragen
im Chat das sind Fragen die sich
wahrscheinlich viele Menschen heute
schon gestellt haben nämlich fragt Sven
Odenthaler Facebook was bedeutet das
jetzt für all jene die sich an
zukünftigen demonstrationsaktionen
Aktion beteiligen würden und auch die
Frage was muss ich vielleicht befürchten
wenn ich mal einen Betrag an die letzte
Generation gespendet habe was bedeutet
dieser Tag heute für diese Menschen ja
die Frage ist interessant hat allerdings
wenig mit dem zu tun was ich gerade
ausgeführt habe ich wollte nur noch ganz
kurz darauf hinweisen dass die Gefahr
besteht dass Menschen die enttäuscht
werden die die in Aktionen angetrieben
werden bei denen es angeblich und alles
geht und bei den entweder heute oder
nicht entschieden werden muss dass sie
enttäuscht sind und wenn 100 Menschen
enttäuscht werden werden 95% sagen okay
dann hat nicht aber fünf werden
möglicherweise sagen dann müssen halt
andere mit Leben da muss man noch
Radikale werden das ist ja immerhin
immer doch eine Gefahr von solchen wie
soll ich sagen von solchen
ein bisschen
religiös teilweise anmutenden Bewegungen
und auf ihre Frage geantwortet ja
natürlich wenn die wenn die Möglichkeit
besteht dass es sich um Straftaten
handelt und dann ist natürlich die
Gefahr gegeben dass wenn man solche
Taten dann begeht dass man dann gegen
solche Straftaten verurteilt wird oder
verfolgt wird jedenfalls und wenn man an
eine Organisation spendet von der sich
herausstellt dass
es ist eine kriminelle Vereinigung ist
dann kann das natürlich im Einzelfall
eine Unterstützung sein ist ja auch ein
Straftatbestand das ist strafbar mit mit
derselben Strafe aber mit einer
geringeren Strafe und da ist
Voraussetzung dass man den Vorsatz hat
und dass man die tatsächlichen Umstände
alle kennt die das begründen kann und
sowas muss man sagen ja in der Tat es
ist es ist ungefähr es ist genauso
gefährlich die zu sagen ich werde
Mitglied der Hells Angels und die Hells
Angels sind irgendeinen chapter ist als
kriminellvereinigung angesehen und wenn
man damit geht wird muss man halt damit
rechnen dass man da verfolgt wird das
ist halt so diese Gefahr besteht das ist
ja genau die Gefahr zu der die
Organisation einlädt und sagt schließt
euch uns an wir begehen öffentlich
wirksame
öffentlichkeitswirksame Straftaten um
die Menschen aufzuhören und wenn man das
nicht will dann soll man halt dann
fräule ist for future Spenden oder
andere Organisationen die solche Taten
nicht ankündigen und deren Tätigkeit
nicht der Zweck natürlich da hat er
Jahren völlig Recht aber deren Tätigkeit
jedenfalls daran besteht teilweise genau
sowas zu tun also das Risiko ist bekannt
und das ist ja auch kein Rätsel und wenn
man das in Kauf nehmen möchte kann
nichts tun das ist ja das Angebot was
diese Organisation macht
kommt zu uns Straftaten die ins
Gefängnis und die Welt wird gerettet ja
müssen jetzt vielleicht junge Menschen
die uns gerade zuschauen die etwas
gespendet haben oder sich einen
Protestmarsch anschließen wollen müssen
die befürchten zukünftig als Teil einer
kriminellen Vereinigung gesehen zu
werden
na im Moment kommt es noch darauf an wo
sich diese Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
befinden soweit sie sich im
Zuständigkeitsbereich der
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft München
befinden wohl schon das ist ja die
Botschaft des heutigen Tages
Unterstützung einer kriminellen
Vereinigung kann jedenfalls in Bayern
auch bedeuten
Spendenaktion
die sich auf eine finanzielle
Unterstützung beschränkt und das zieht
natürlich wenn man sich zurück erinnert
an die unzählige Tradition der
Unterstützung terroristischer
Vereinigung der 1970er Jahren das kann
also hingehen bis zum
Werben durch
Plakataktion
Entschuldigung durch ähnliches
geht also sehr sehr weit in ein Vorfeld
hinein und das halte ich für eine
gefährliche Entwicklung die bisher mir
nicht veranlasst erscheint ich sehe
einen substanziellen Unterschied
zwischen der Unterstützung der Hells
Angels die jetzt zitiert worden sind
oder der Mafia und der letzten
Generation weil die Taten um dies hier
geht
eine andere Qualität haben und weil das
was ich dort unterstützen möchte ich
rede gar nicht da sagt der Fischer
völlig zu Recht von den Fernzielen die
hier beabsichtigt sind sondern ich rede
zunächst mal von den Taten die mit
diesen
Unterstützungsleistung begangen werden
weil die Taten um dies hier geht nicht
Schutzgeld Erpressung sind nicht äh das
Töten
von
Zeugen sind die in Strafverfahren
gefährlich werden können oder die
Entführung sondern es geht hier zunächst
mal um sach Beschädigung um Nötigung und
um andere minder schwere Delikte die das
Maß das Gesetz nach meiner Lesart
aufrichtet errichtet nicht reißen und
deshalb nicht als kriminelle Vereinigung
verfolgt werden sollten
hey Jahn herr Fischer ich danke Ihnen
für diese Diskussion und wünschen alles
Gute
und ich war für zum Schluss noch mal im
Blick in die Kommentare und guck mal so
drauf was eure Meinung da draußen ist ob
sie auch immer so juristisch begründet
ist wir werden mal sehen Julia Baro
schreibt auf Facebook diese Aktion ist
ein Armutszeugnis für unsere Demokratie
Aktivisten ein Aktivisten einschüchtern
ist das entscheidende Stichwort mir
schreibt aber auch jemand fragt auch mal
einer was der Blödsinn kostet abgesehen
von der tatsächlichen Nötigung und der
Freiheitsberaubung kosten die
Einsatzkräfte die sich um die kümmern
einen Arsch voll Geld ja also bei euch
gehen die Meinung ziemlich auseinander
und wir haben ja gerade schon gehört wir
können da ganz ganz viel darüber
sprechen aber eigentlich ist gerade noch
gar nicht so richtig viel klar nach
diesem anfangs Verdacht danke dass ihr
eingeschaltet habt und danke für eure
Kommentare bis zum nächsten Mal